good morning Hank it's Monday Labor Day
2010 I got attacked by a baby so like
I'm totally in love with your video from
Friday where you exploit the
relationship between privatized risk and
public regulation I think there was
something about your intelligence and
your passion that made me think I need
to start talking about the issues that
are near and dear to my heart even when
they're controversial so I'm gonna do it
Hank I'm just gonna say it I hate
pennies so in the United States of
America we have money which we use to
facilitate the exchange of goods and
services the smallest unit of American
money is the penny which is worth 1/100
of a dollar so Hank here's the deal
because of inflation in 1972 a penny was
worth what a nickel is worth today and
yet in 1972 our economy managed to
function just fine without having a coin
that was worth one-fifth of a penny
here's what bothers me Hank it cost the
United States Mint 1 point 7 cents to
make a penny which means that every year
seventy million dollars of federal tax
money goes to subsidizing the existence
of the penny now like we could solve
that problem by using steel instead of
zinc to make pennies but that wouldn't
address the underlying problem which is
that pennies are worthless no they are
they are - no because things that are
worthless are worth nothing and pennies
are worth much less than nothing so
there's this very important idea in
economics called opportunity cost that
I'm not going to explain but basically
anytime you are doing something you
could be doing something else but
several studies have proven that the
time Americans spend fiddling with
pennies costs us money as much as a
billion dollars a year so every year
American taxpayers pay seventy million
dollars to have the opportunity to lose
a billion dollars in productivity costs
there is no legitimate argument in favor
of the penny many studies have shown
that it wouldn't raise prices it
wouldn't cut charitable contributions
the only institution in the world that
benefits from the existence of the penny
is a company in Greenville Tennessee
called jardins Inc products for everyone
else in the United States pennies are
not just worthless but incredibly
expensive but that is not even the
ultimate reason to get rid of the penny
the ultimate reason is that as I said in
the beginning of this video money exists
to facilitate the exchange of goods and
services and the pennies don't do that
effectively all the places we usually
use
coins like parking meters and vending
machines don't accept pennies because
they are worthless I am turning into a
giant what about oh you know the only
thing I hate more than pennies Hank
nickels a nickel which is worth five
cents
takes more than nine cents to produce
imagine if you will Hank a situation in
which you walk into a bank and you say I
have here this nickel would you like to
give me nine cents for it and the bank
says yes that's what's happening with
the US Mint the real solution is that we
have three coins a dime a 50-cent piece
and a dollar if we did this we would
save billions of dollars annually enough
to pay for many of the job creation
programs that politicians are fighting
about on television all the time
but we won't tank for two reasons first
because we're species of sentimentalists
the only reason we have pennies is
because people like pennies and they
grew up with pennies and they like
Abraham Lincoln but let me tell you if
Abraham Lincoln were alive today he
would say why is my face on a coin that
is worth one 26th of what a penny was
worth when I was president and second
because it is not an issue you can
really fight about
so like about half the main advocates
for coinage reform in the last ten years
have been Republicans and about half
been Democrats because it's not a
political issue it's just a rational
issue it's not the kind of issue that
fires up your base or gets you real
ected it's just something that's gonna
save Americans billions of dollars and
create lots of exciting efficiencies in
our economy and eliminate these
disgusting bacteria-ridden discs of suck
that failed to facilitate Commerce all
right but speaking of Commerce Hank just
a reminder to nerdfighteria a
vlogbrothers shirt designed by
nerdfighter Vaughn Dale Swain is
available for pre-order at dftba.com
link in the doobly-doo it's only
available for one more week if you want
one get it now we take paypal credit
card each Eck really anything except for
pennies and nickels
Hank I'll see you on Wednesday